Traduttore: Valentina Riccarelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Ognuno di noi ha un proprio talento.
Berruto ne ha tantissimi,
io ne ho uno solo:
sono cintura nera di trattoria,
cioè sono proprio un appassionato,
tutto il mio corpo, il mio grande corpo.
Ma non sono l'unico,
perché una ricerca della
Federazione Italiana Pubblici Esercizi,
uscita dieci giorni fa,
che dice che in Italia
sono 34 i milioni di italiani
che mangiano molto frequentemente
fuori casa, e sono in aumento.
Siamo gli unici in Europa che vanno
sempre di più a mangiare fuori casa
e sono 5 milioni quelli che vanno
a mangiare fuori casa a pranzo
3-4 volte la settimana, quindi spessissimo
praticamente tutti i giorni lavorativi.
Fate i conti, cioè li ho fatti io
perché mi sono applicato:
5 milioni di italiani
per 250 giorni lavorativi,
la spesa media è tra i 5 e i 10 Euro,
facciamo 7 e mezzo.
Avete fatto il conto sicuramente,
ma ve lo dico io:
fa quasi 10 miliardi,
cioè sono quasi 10 miliardi di Euro
che tutti gli anni
spendiamo in pause pranzo.
Un sacco di soldi!
Tutto il comparto vale quasi 90 miliardi,
cioè quindi 3 finanziarie.
Le nostre pause pranzo valgono
un terzo di una manovra di assestamento.
Ciononostante - intanto li mangiate.
Ciononostante, di trattorie
ci occupiamo molto poco;
sono molto poco sui giornali,
molto poco sulle guide, come mai?
Perché in generale ci occupiamo più
delle rappresentazioni che della realtà:
guardiamo molto il calcio,
ma poi facciamo poco sport;
sicuramente tra i presenti
siete sempre su YouPorn
ma fate pochissimo l'amore.
(Risate)
Sapete tutto della vita di Carlo Cracco,
di Antonino Cannav... c'è qualcuno che...
sai che sto parlando di te
-c'è qualcuno che sa di chi sto parlando.
Sappiamo tutto della vita
di Cannavacciuolo, di Cracco, etc etc
però magari non sappiamo come si chiama
il signore che cucina
nel bar dove andiamo
a mangiare tutti i giorni.
Facciamo un esperimento.
Quanti di voi hanno mangiato
in un ristorante da più di 100 Euro
nell'ultima settimana?
Non è che vi mandiamo Equitalia.
Nessuno!? Uno! Oh, meno male!
Equitalia? È li.
(Risate)
Quanti di voi hanno mangiato
in una trattoria nell'ultima settimana?
Io sicuramente.
Bene: questo dimostra che le trattorie,
appunto, sono molto popolari.
Io esattamente come voi, vi dicevo,
vado a mangiare sempre in trattoria
perché lo faccio per mestiere,
recensisco trattorie per "Repubblica".
La differenza tra me e un cliente normale
è che io tutti i giorni cambio trattoria,
cioè ne provo sempre di diverse.
Quindi, in un anno ne provo 100-150.
Fino adesso ne avrò provate un 1000-1500,
quindi la cintura nera
me la merito, diciamo.
E in questi anni ho capito che cos'è
che mi piace di una trattoria,
cioè cosa distingue una trattoria buona
da una trattoria normale.
Ora, intanto la definizione di trattoria:
per la Treccani una trattoria
è tipo un ristorante, ma più semplice.
Ora, non voglio far torto a Treccani,
però ci si poteva sforzare un po' di più.
Allora io dico che secondo me la trattoria
è sì, tipo un ristorante ma più semplice;
ma soprattutto è un posto
dove si mangia a pranzo
e dove vanno a mangiare lavoratori,
studenti, impiegati, pensionati,
cioè tutti quelli che hanno bisogno
di rispondere al più primordiale
dei bisogni, che è la fame.
Cioè, chi va a mangiare fuori
per fame e non per piacere.
Dunque cosa distingue una trattoria buona
da una trattoria normale?
Secondo me 2 elementi che non sono fisici,
cioè sono fisici ma non sono cose.
Non sono le tovaglie a quadretti,
non sono i lampadari in ferro battuto,
non è il fiasco di Chianti con la paglia.
Quindi, quando andate a Trastevere,
non fatevi prendere da queste robe qua.
Quello che conta in una trattoria
sono due ingredienti, sono 2 persone:
uno è il cuoco, chiaro, cioè una persona
che ci sappia fare col cibo;
l'altra è l'oste, una persona
che ci sappia fare con le persone,
perché la trattoria è una questione
soprattutto d'accoglienza.
Troppo spesso si fa caso al cuoco,
ma si fa poco caso all'oste.
Invece, quando entrate in trattoria
guardate prima di tutto le persone.
Possono non esserci le tovaglie,
possono essere di fiandra;
voi guardate com'è l'oste,
guardate come è il cuoco
e quindi prendete una decisione.
Però direte: spendiamo
10 miliardi all'anno, bla bla bla,
l'Italia è l'unico paese in crescita.
Perché dedicare
questi 8 minuti alle trattorie?
Perché le trattorie sono in crisi.
Sono in difficoltà,
perché hanno molti nemici.
Un nemico è molto grosso
e non lo trattiamo oggi
- è l'ipernormazione, l'ipertassazione,
il costo del lavoro, i voucher,
questi dibattiti qui.
Tutte cose che fanno si che,
quello che un tempo era un investimento,
quello in una trattoria
che si ripagava in 3 anni,
adesso necessita di 10.
Uno che apriva una trattoria 20 anni fa
ci metteva 3 anni
per rientrare nei quattrini.
Adesso se gli va bene, se non muore prima,
come sto facendo io adesso,
(Risate)
ce ne vogliono 10.
Ma invece mi voglio concentrare
su 2 nemici della trattoria,
due nemici che in realtà ci coinvolgono.
Uno è una certa retorica:
la retorica del prodotto,
la retorica della tradizione
e la retorica della
territorialità, del territorio.
Sarò velocissimo, sul territorio
- sono tutte cose buone,
ma che se diventano retoriche
diventano cattive.
Sul territorio, le mie trattorie
preferite, e io sono di Torino,
sono Abruzzesi, Siciliane, Calabresi,
perché sono trattorie torinesi
anche loro, no?
Cioè sono qua da 30 anni, 40 anni..
Quindi non fatevi prendere
da sta roba del local a tutti i costi.
Sui prodotti. certo,
bisogna avere prodotti buoni,
ma i prodotti d'eccellenza
riguardano solo il signore
che è andato a mangiare
in un posto da 100 Euro.
Noi invece dobbiamo occuparci
di avere prodotti di qualità
nella fascia media, non al top.
E lo stesso la tradizione.
C'è una famosa frase del giornalista
Michael Pollan, che dice:
"Non mangiare niente che la tua bisnonna
non riconoscerebbe come cibo".
Ora, è una frase...
(Applausi)
Michael Pollan ha sicuramente ragione:
ma andando indietro
di bisnonna in bisnonna
dovremmo mangiare ancora le bacche,
cioè nel senso che...
Invece tutta la tradizione
è stata contemporanea,
quindi non stiamo troppo a...
L'altro nemico delle trattorie
siamo un po' noi, non voi, ma noi critici,
che le consideriamo poco sui giornali,
sulle riviste, sulle guide.
Le trattorie hanno un amico solo,
e questo amico siamo noi,
noi tutti che spendiamo
i nostri 10 miliardi all'anno.
Ma non siamo abbastanza forti,
abbiamo bisogno di un alleato,
e sto per dirvi un alleato
che è particolarmente scomodo,
cioè è diciamo il Verdini
degli alleati delle trattorie.
Questo alleato - si può dire Verdini
perché tanto è scomodo per tutti,
che uno sia...
(Risate)
Questo alleato si chiama TripAdvisor.
Io so che molti di voi odiano TripAdvisor,
perché è pieno di commenti falsi,
di marchette, eccetera eccetera -
Ma invece è uno strumento potente.
E visto che esiste, non possiamo
far finta che non esista.
Vi racconto solo questo piccolo aneddoto.
Qualche tempo fa, in una trattoria,
vicino a me c'era una signora.
Le dico: "Si mangia bene qua".
Lei dice: "Si mangia benissimo,
è la trattoria migliore della vita!"
E dico: "Brava signora,
son felice che lei sia contenta".
Dice: "Tutte le volte che torno a casa,
faccio un commento su TripAdvisor".
Dico: "Brava signora, così finalmente..."
E lei dice: "No, ma io vado a casa
e lascio un pallino".
Io: "Come!? Se è felice,
perché lascia un pallino?"
"Si, lascio un pallino così la gente
non viene qua a rompere le palle".
E io dico: "Ma signora..."
(Risate e Applausi)
L'applauso è per la signora,
poi glielo porterò.
Allora noi dobbiamo cambiare verso
-come si dice alla Leopolda,
a questo TripAdvisor,
dobbiamo far la nostra parte.
Quando andate a mangiare in una trattoria
e mangiate bene, tornate a casa
e portate una carezza
alla vostra trattoria da parte mia.
(Risate)
Mettete 5 pallini,
e questa è la mia "call to action".
E quindi vi chiedo davvero
di usare TripAdvisor-
io non lavoro per TripAdvisor, eh!
Usatelo bene.
E il mio motto finale è:
"La forza scorre potente in TripAdvisor,
ma è il lato oscuro della forza.
Riportiamo TripAdvisor
sul lato chiaro della forza".
Grazie mille.
(Applausi)